if you want to show cut your path to
riches model success find someone who's
already done what you're trying to do
figure out what work for them and make
it work for you success leaves clues you
just have to follow them otherwise
you're going to spend countless hours
resources dollars energy frustration
going in the wrong path and in a path
that you already know doesn't work if
you just follow the clues whatever
problem you're facing right now has
already been solved by somebody you just
need to find them and put that solution
to work for you you don't have to be a
genius to have success as an
entrepreneur you just have to model
success when Howard Schultz was now the
CEO of Starbucks was looking for a new
business opportunity he went to Italy on
a family vacation and he saw that for
Italians the coffee shop was the center
of life people met at the coffee shop
they spent hours they're talking he
looked at America and saw the dunkin
donuts of the world where you're in and
out you don't spend much time at the
coffee shop and so we say what if we
just brought this concept that's already
worked for decades for Italians I bring
it to America and starbucks was born and
it had rapid success because it was
already used in a model that worked he
didn't reinvent the wheel he didn't come
up with a brand new concept an idea he
just took what was already working for
somebody else I made it work for him
when I had my first software business a
software company biotech software and I
was in charge of bringing in new sales
only problem was I was 19 had no idea
what I was doing had no software
background and no science background at
all and so I was panicking I was a
little scared and excited but scared and
once the you know panic initial and the
initial panic wore off I said to myself
you know what I'm not the first guy to
go out and try to sell software before
and I look the companies like Microsoft
and mcafee and into it and looked at how
they got started I don't care how Bill
Gates mixing action million dollars
right now it's not interesting how did
he go from zero to his first meal how do
you go from that initial concept to
making that first million dollars that
was interesting to me
and we've research these companies and
found that what worked for them and we
put it to work for our business and it
worked you can apply the same thing to
your company even any personal
challenges you have whatever challenge
you're facing right now somebody has
already accomplished it and solved it
you just have to find out who they are
model their strategies for success and
make it work for you you don't have to
be a genius you don't have to reinvent
the wheel every time find the person has
already done it and make it work for you
good luck